the jurogan experience when
you were doing this he was just a local
celebrity in the new york restaurant
scene right he had no reservations
started yet or this was kitchen
confidential yeah so kitchen
confidential came out in 2000 so he was
already
on the rise i think he was a season or
two into a cook's tour which was the
very first iteration of tony on
television
uh but there was no you know he was
always would say like i've got my 15
minutes i have no expectation that this
is gonna you know last forever i'm gonna
do as much as i can while i can but
i think he was always waiting for
someone to pull the rug out from under
him you know
as far as being a celebrity whatever
yeah
he was it was really interesting it's
like it's it's hard for people to
realize that other people appreciate
them i think especially
people that are genuinely humble you
know what like he's a he was a genuinely
humble person like he really didn't buy
into his own [ __ ] at all right so
when you would talk to him about it he
was like this could [ __ ] end terribly
at any moment you know
yeah i remember being with him in the
green room uh he did a book tour for our
the cookbook appetites that we wrote
together in 2016 and he did a series of
lectures basically like a one-hour
stand-up routine
in these theaters and then book signing
so we were at the last one at bam in
brooklyn and in the green room
and he was just like oh god i [ __ ]
hate this i feel like such a what's the
word he's such a fraud yeah and i was
like what are you talking about you just
had like 13 sold out shows the book is
doing amazing like you're
literally tony bourdain he was like yeah
it's i just it's all [ __ ] i'm
embarrassed that people have paid money
to come and see me talk you know it was
really
illustrative to me to hear him talk like
that you know to realize like he doesn't
he doesn't think he's
as great as we know he is you know
that's a common thing
amongst uh at least my people amongst
comedians it's it's it's in many um
successful people it's called imposter
syndrome
and it exists because you have a certain
sort of a set perception of who you were
just going through life sort of
anonymously and then it radically
changes and it doesn't feel real and so
to other people who have just discovered
you they love your show they love your
writing they love your your your take on
the world as you travel and eat
everywhere you know you think like i'm
the same [ __ ] idiot that i was you
know he's he's probably thinking he's
the same guy he was in 95. and now here
all these people love him it doesn't
make any sense and just feel like this
is going to fall apart this is fake yeah
but that's also why he was so
interesting
is because like the people that are like
legitimately full of themselves and
really think everything they're doing is
great are gross
yeah they they're gross they come off
gross when you see someone write like
i'm the [ __ ] you know like what like
that is so gross
and it's such the opposite of what
anybody ever wants to hear you know and
maybe you could say it in jest and you
know people think it's funny but for the
most part the people that are really
enamored with themselves and their work
are just not nearly as interesting as
the people that are tortured by it
it's it's such a conundrum right it's
like a guy like tony who is such an
interesting fascinating person just to
talk to just have a commu a conversation
with because he had such a clear
perspective on things the way he looked
at things he was very aesthetic he had
like a very into like he had us he
enjoyed certain style of communication
and of hanging out and like he had there
was an art to just conversation with the
guy
so
it's like it makes sense that he hated
himself yeah you know in the most [ __ ]
up way possible it makes sense yeah i
think too there was this disconnect
between the guy that he was before he
got famous and the guy after you know
and i think he always thought about how
the guy the old guy probably would have
made fun of the new guy you know and or
he would have he and all his his buddies
who were cooks stuck in the kitchen
would would sort of hate this you know
guy with the expensive shoes and the
nice apartment and flying first class
you know yeah that's what happens you
know you you want to be punk rock and
then all of a sudden you have a million
dollars in the bank you're like hey
yeah yeah
i think i'm gonna eat it in a nice place
tonight
you know i think i'm gonna i think i'm
gonna buy a watch you know it's it
you really can feel like a fraud it's
fascinating because so many people are
really
they're haunted in a lot of ways by the
past and you know there's sort of like
this uh
rebellious
rigid attitude that you develop when
you're struggling when you're coming up
and
you know it becomes like the structure
of where your attitude comes from and
then when that structure is sort of
removed by success
in tony's case and then you're left with
okay i'm not even like in his eyes
he had done all these hours of being in
the kitchen right the real work those
long days and long nights and that's
there was something noble about that
right and then
all of a sudden he's just going to visit
these guys and he's not in the game
anymore
and you know he's going to visit these
incredible cooks and seeing these
amazing dishes and these insane
restaurants and i think
part of that he felt like a little bit
of a fraud because of that yeah yeah he
was always very careful to say
i'm i was not a great chef you know i
think it's very people kind of just in
the same way that people thought that
you know the whole with the ai thing
that it was
all of this the movie versus 45 seconds
there's just a
a glossing over a kind of uh sloppiness
of recollection and so
because he was a chef everyone you know
would say oh he was the a great chef or
a celebrity chef or a famous chef you
know and he was always really careful to
say i wasn't you know i was like i was
good at leading a kitchen i was good at
getting food out on time but i was not
in any way
a world famous creative chef i was a
leader of men you know and there was i
think a lot of
uh
i don't know insecurity but just a just
a recognition that he wasn't the kind of
chef uh like eric repair his good friend
or any of these guys that he really
admired you know and he wanted everyone
to be to know that he knew that too no
yes that just the genuine humility about
him
watch the entire episode for free only
on spotify